coaches parents whoever they think oh
well the the way to develop discipline
and toughness is
take the navy seals method which is put
people through some really difficult
things and then they'll get really tough
no that's not what the navy seals even
do i talked to a really good former
college athlete of mine who went on into
the military and now i was trying for
the special forces
and he put it pretty succinctly it was
like
steve before we go out and do all the
crazy stuff like the survival training
we're doing
we sit in a classroom lecture after
lecture powerpoint after powerpoint i've
got a 600 page book filled with telling
me how what to do mentally and
physically to handle whatever situation
i'm coming at and i have to learn and
understand that yeah and it's only after
i learn those skills that i'm then put
in a place that simulates what i'll feel
like and experience so that i can try
those skills out right to see if you're
able to access that skill set under
pressure and duress exactly